هذا تحذير للبشر نقول لها باخر كلمه خاصه
الرجال خصوبتكم في خطر بل وتراجعت الى
النصف خلال اخر خمسين سنه خطير خطير هذا
الخبر على فكره قد يكون الموضوع بالفعل
غريب مشاهدينا خاصه مع ارتفاع عدد السكان
لكن التحذيرات تصل لحد ان الاخصاب الصناعي
قد يكون صعبا حتى هذه المخاوف اثارها
تقرير طبي اعده باحثون من جامعه
المجريه واعتمدوا على مراجعه 27 الف دراسه
اكدوا مشاهدينا ان جوده السائل المنوي لدى
الرجل انخفضت بوتيره متسارعه عالميا منذ
مطلع القرن الحادي والعشرين التفاصيل كلها
ستكون على سرحان قبل ان نناقش ضيفنا في
هذا الموضوع منتخبنا ناصي على منتخب
الرجال في تناقص
يعني في هذا الشرح حاولنا تبسيط الموضوع
ومع الضيف سيكون هناك الكثير من التوضيحات
فقياس نشاط السائل المنوي لدى الرجل يجرى
بالاعتماد على ما يعرف بتكسير الحمض
النووي التحليل يقيس ماده الدي ان ايه في
السائل المنوي كما يرصد الاجزاء الجيليه
غير المتضرره والسبب هو انه كلما كان
الحمض النووي اكثر تعرضا للتفتيت
والانقسام نقصت جوده الحيوانات المنويه
وتراجعت قدرتها على الاخصاب كما يمكن ان
يؤدي الى فشل الحمل في حال تفتته بشكل
كبير فلا يكمل الجنين المده العاديه في
الرحم بحسب المعايير الطبيه فانه في حال
كان تكسير الماده الوراثيه في السائل
المنوي اقل من 25% فانه يضل في حاله
ممتازه وفي حال تخطى عتبه الخمسين بالمئه
فان الاخصاب الصناعي عنه
يكون اهداف فرصه ضعيفه
وتشير التقارير الى ان عدد من الاسباب
تؤثر سلبا على الحيوانات المنويه لدى
الرجل وهي التلوث والتدخين والعمر وبعض
الامراض
[موسيقى]
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع الخطير والمهم ينضم
الينا المتخصص في جراحه المسالك البوليه
الدكتور ياسر جاسم دكتور صباح الخير هذا
الخبر مغلق يا دكتور فريقنا خلاص سينتقرض
ناقصين الرجال ماكو رجال ام ماذا يحدث لنا
ما تنقرض ولكن
هذه التقارير تاكد في مشكله تحتاج الى حل
او تحتاج الى تداخل
للحفاظ على توازن الذكور مع الاناث
والحفاظ على
نوعيه السائل المنوي المسؤول عن الخصوبه
بتجنب الاثار
التكنولوجيا الحديثه الادويه بعض الادويه
كذلك
بالسموم
الكيميكال الاشعه
الكمبيوترز اللابتوب سكول كل هاي الاشياء
اذا كان في في الحضن وحراره لفترات
تكون سبب هذا الموضوع
رح نرجع 50% في اخر خمسين سنه يعني هل
معنى ذلك فقدوا 50% من قدرتهم على الانجاب
ام انه المعادله مختلفه المعادله مختلفه
ولكن
ظروف والتكنولوجي والحياه الجديده يعني
قبل خمسين سنه ما كان الناس تستخدم
الادويه بهاي الكميه اعمار الناس الغذاء
كانت تاكل غداء صحي الان معلبات في اشياء
كثيره اضافه الى الاشعات كل هاي الاشياء
تكون سبب
يعني تاثير سلبي على الخصوبه هذه الدراسات
بالارقام صحيح ولكن الواقع ليس بهذا السوء
هذا الرعب اطمن ياتي ما لقى يعني ما خلى
شيء كل شيء عندك نقص فيه هناك مكملات
غذائيه عندك مرض هناك علاج الان ماذا عن
هذا هذه الدراسه هل هناك شيء يسند
ويعدل كفه المي اذا اردنا ان نقول نعم في
مكملات ولا نعم في تجنب السبب او الاقلاع
من التعرض للهاي الاشياء ذكرناها اللي
تؤثر على الخصوبه اضافه الى وجود بعض
يعني الاكسده اللي تقضي على الجذور الحره
اللي هي مسؤوله عن جزء كبير من تخريب او
خراب
التركيب الكروموسومي للحيوان انا بس حتى
افهم انا ماني شاطر بالجانب العلمي الان
الاكس والواي عند الرجل هل بمعنى انه قوه
الرجل في عمليه الاخصاب ام انه فقط هو
ينتج الاكس مش الواي لا لا
هذه الدراسه كيف هي تتحدث بالضبط على
تاثير العوامل الخارجيه على الكروموسوم
يعني الكروموسوم صحيح اكس واي
انت ذكرت في بدايه حديثك بانه من ابرز
الحلول هي تفادي المسبب كيف بنقدر نتفادى
اسلوب حياه فيها كمبيوترز وفيها اشعاع
وفيها كيماويات في الاكل اللي عم ناكله
فيها ادويه كيف ممكن يعني هذا اسلوب
حياتنا اصلا ممكن لازم نحاول نقلل الكميات
مثلا اوقات التعرض للكمبيوتر كل المكان
حاول نتجن مستخدم طريقه اخرى والفترات نفس
الشيء بالتعرض للاشعه تعرض للادويه
للمواد الكيماويه الضاره مثل الحديد
الرصاص والكادميوم كل هاي الاشياء يعني
بكميات وفترات التعرض كل ما قلت كل ما
تكون امورنا احسن
مارس رياضه الرياضه الاكل الصحي تجنب هذه
الملوثات اكيد بالتاكيد الدكتور ياسر ياسر
جاسم ان شاء الله الله يزيد الخصوبه
شكرا شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات